we got a new on his trailer today people
use also what happens like when you just
you could probably take out the stuff of
me being like yeah with a stripper I
need to pee yes I will take that out
it's okay most definitely
[Music]
how's it going reject nation in his I
John Humphrey and with me today new
guest to the channel its Keaton Marquis
from from all over the interval I mean
you're like a Jill of various trades I
do I do a lot of different things well
what are you doing here then haha
we're bad people we actually met doing
haunted house work years which is about
as fun and interesting as you can get
from dusk till dawn right yeah yeah I
was santanico we were both strippers in
our own way yeah well you were you're
the front near the doorman I made $20
doorman doorman I did well people
through tips at me we have this cuz it
only happened once but hey guess what we
got a new honest trailer today which is
always fun I mean you know honest
trailers right yes I do
what's up John Bailey do you like
science fiction well the red team today
I know where this cuz Elon Musk you know
they SpaceX launch that rocket or
something like the space mood yeah cool
yeah well speaking of space and science
fiction we got a little bit of science
fiction to jump into today new honest
trailer yeah Doctor Who and there are
two of them we're gonna cover the modern
one because I mean I've seen some Doctor
Who you seen a lot more doctors a lot
more dargor than me shadow tell my
tenant girls out there although I do
love Capaldi as well they're like now
closing
you know I'm an Eccleston which is what
I'm calling us who like that doctor
doctor 9 alright I can only imagine what
this is gonna be this is a thick honest
trailer to my getting 10 minutes I know
yeah I feel like I'm gonna go do a
recording like singing or something if
you're like more accurate that's the
idea I want you to harmonize with John
Bailey great
from fancy PBS comes a share it takes
place anywhere in the universe at any
time the past present and future where
anything can happen and why would the
continuity matters Doctor Who get ready
for a continuation of the original
series that picks up after 16 years off
the air because all the British nerds
who grew up with classic who finally got
old enough to call the shots at the BBC
to choke a telenovela I think you needed
[Music]
meet the doctor he's not an actual
doctor but an alien who named himself
that Isabel the name I chose it's the
Tom Tom it's like a promise you make
even though the word doctor was created
to describe him the word for healer and
wise man we kept that word from you you
know yeah that's not the first time boys
magic a faulty tortoise from the planet
Gallifrey who sometimes kind of a dig
funny little humor breeds okay got
rounded most things but to casual
viewers he's a funny man with the time
machine who takes lady's own adventures
who's also kind of a dick that kind of
time you're an idiot
watch it - new time equipped with a
sonic screwdriver and psychic paper
- devices with the power to speed up the
plot yeah Time Machine with the power to
break when the plot needs to slow down
stop maybe they brake less we didn't
keep exploding us out of it
just a thought watch the spatial justice
warrior travel all around the known
universe from the streets of London to
working-class British mining towns after
the quaintest little English villages no
they're very oh no I do the Liao's he'll
fly off to the far reaches of the CGI
universe everything is still extremely
British UK Britain Suns all the sun's by
his side as always is his trusty
companion usually a cute girl because
ratings who after a few seasons of
adventure usually hazard life ruined
[Music]
if she's Oh bills my favorite she'll
follow law to keep the doctor grounded
give them someone to talk to and after
this mostly platonic would not always
love interest no sex except Bernardo
that one was purely physical oh we're so
long
they build 13-week castings of the main
character into the lore then hit that
limit and pool even born out of a cry as
each actor brings a new spin to the
alien who's seen of stars but looks like
he's never seen the Sun whether it's
Eccleston the only doctor of the modern
era to regenerate due to creative
differences with a BBC the dependent the
unquestioned master of Sterlings sadly
into the middle distance with the wavy
arms of an inflatable tube man Peter
Capaldi who reimagined the doctor as
your uncle never got married and moved
to Vegas in his 40s I was being all down
with a kid Santa to notice we're doing
Whitaker you know dr. which no matter
how she performs is one of the least
outrageous things this ridiculous show
has ever done demands all powerful
villains to go up against and the doctor
has mustered the weak imagine the very
small cubes or something invisible to
save on the effects budget
or something we've seen a million times
before but an alien or anything so much
are among the best in Saipan the
Cybermen emotionless robots who can only
be defeated by feelings arch-nemesis
but is in the middle of this list so you
do the math the weeping angels every
appearance until they're about as scary
as ghostbusters to
and the doctors other Gryba the rush
applauded stuffed into crap metal hoes
who spend their entire life shouting
commands at people they hate when the
series fanny arcs there with the like
fans and confuse newcomers like the
seasons where the world keeps ending
while just kidding it can reverse the
planets rotation like Superman high
restored the seasons where the doctor
falls in love with his companion only to
lose her for all eternity
[Music]
he'll make a copy of himself and they
live happily ever after
why this doctor comes with inevitability
of his own dead or the seasons where
he's haunted by the knowledge that he's
triggered the genocide of his own people
she won't picture me that just kidding
and he actually saved everyone but
doesn't remember it yeah
actually suggesting that we change our
own personal history sure that'll work
wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey whatever so
run down your nearest hallway I hope
they starring every British actor ever
yes
plan yeah of course I have a plan hey
start spouting technobabble
like the universe depends on it
Cassadine energy not her transmission
cables away Ben sticks it into the
receptacle and then it needs of the
remaining option energy because you're
about to get some of the greatest
standalone episodes in sci-fi history
with a bunch of momentum killing
serialization crammed into service the
diehards what I've said and done let's
still try to be more like the doctor
never cruel or cowardly just enjoy the
ride in my food no no make it hard to
love you sometimes the leftover hi Kenny
to scary poppins tell me you're hoping
the appearance of the repeated meme just
the town Harry and Ron at the same time
I want a girl with a joke skirt in the
long jacket the mrs. Frizzle who's just
kind of era we barely knew ye Oh
spin-doctors a great glass doctor
Vader's that time Rose was on weakest
link you know
you bastards twice sorry Rory but you
just died the gravestone if it's all
with the same name as me that thing
today which does yeah we British actor
yeah
oh no that was a British actor Game of
Thrones
every two days of our lives a future
player haha that was a lot of who to get
through it wasn't so bad let's see what
that classic series is all about want to
see where the adventures of the doctor
all began then click above to see our
trailer for classic Doctor Who spanning
decades of television that happened
before the reboot grab a jelly baby and
check it out it's Affairs I wear a fez
now places are cool it's more like a big
ball of wibbly-wobbly
the stove I've always wondered where
that quote came from
oh really wobbly timey wimey said me i
knows a who thing but i've never seen
the episode or whatever where that
that's a ten thing right yes see the
magic about this video is even though i
haven't seen much of Doctor Who I have
witnessed most every one of these I'm
sure in the limited amount like maybe
not Rory dying a bunch of times but
everything else is like exactly what
that's like kind of the the cool thing
about Doctor Who and they'll be
interested to see what they do in this
new season because different people are
taking it over but there's really yeah
no see Moffat anymore they really really
cater to the fans which is okay very
lovely but they give us a lot of fun
things to follow yeah and a lot of
callbacks it's kind of like thor
ragnarok but a TV series alright like
actually something they make fun of
themselves they do all that this is a
little bit more meta now yes a little
bit more self referential oh yeah I feel
like if you're gonna do a massive
overhaul and be like remember those
rules we set up about the 13
regeneration so we can't do that we're
gonna make more you can break the rules
people like this too much damn it why
did Eccleston have to leave so soon I
feel like anybody behind the scenes
burger that show would be like damn it
we only get a limited number of these at
least at the time oh my god yeah the
graphics are just rough the very first
episode I ever watched a doctor who was
the weeping angels episode and I was
told I've seen that needed to be the
first one I watched because that would
kind of help me understand what doctor
who was was kind of it's a good nutshell
and it's it's very much like the doctors
barely in it very much just kind of
taken out of the world but they like the
doctors in the beginning in the end and
it's terrifying that episode yes real
way to make you never like a tease
around a statue ever Oh ever never in a
graveyard and that was called blink I
believe it so you're trying to get any
of your friends or family members in to
Doctor Who I highly recommend watching
blink first and then starting at the
beginning
that's oh that was a kind of a sharp
barb but he brings at that point about a
bunch of really amazing standalone
episodes like a bunch of things in
between the connecting together for the
fans like would you agree with that or
absolutely like it's it's so random and
I sometimes get frustrated with Doctor
Who when they have like episodes that
are like the story are expanding like
it's a three episode arc because I like
that each week I'm going to a different
place or time period or something new is
gonna happen yeah new yeah basically
monster of the week and sometimes those
episodes that are like multiple episodes
arcs I get a little slow because there's
only so much of this wibbly-wobbly
timey-wimey
crap I love it as long as seasons are
you can't be super consistent I would
imagine with how much like serial stuff
you're doing between all the little
isolated incidents yeah well there's
really no rules in this universe even
when they say there's rules they'll
maybe like a season later we'll be like
actually this is why that rule doesn't
apply anymore yeah that was a thing I
thought was funny about this when they
bring up the sonic screwdriver about how
like it's just whenever we need to move
the plot along let's just bring that
thing out it's so funny because
sometimes a sonic screwdriver like it
works really really well and then
somebody's like it won't work on this
and it's like but it worked on that last
season is it makes me wonder is it just
writers coming up with something and
then somebody across the room ten days
later goes wait a minute we already did
that we'll just add another line or
something like or two they does not care
that I think they care obviously they
care it's just such a part of pop
culture like in our culture now it's a
few things in its like original format
that is endured for so long and is still
like popular more popular than ever yeah
it's like survivor yeah which will never
go away survivors on went 37 yeah I work
on sorry that was my first job out of
college oh right yeah I was I detest the
challenges out on location and then I
started working with wardrobe and
casting so they have wardrobe on
Survivor
you yeah casting seems like a whole
thing yeah comment below and you know
I'll make sure you get yeah no but
seriously send your stuff in now we need
some more like nerds and gamers on the
show they always do the best it's not
the big strong guys who do the best it's
like the nerdy gamers who are good at
strategy really yes I promise you guys
get on national TV I've never found a
similarity between Doctor Who and
Survivor but you just hey maybe in the
next season we'll see a survivor episode
because we're like you know the doctor
and the companion are in a survivor and
the companion is like what the hell are
we doing here and the doctors like
something's wrong they probably have
there's so many Doctor Who at this point
there's very specific ones I remember
but yeah I don't know if they've done
that see watching this got funny to me
because after a while I started to be
like I can't tell if these are things
that I've seen or not but a lot of them
look familiar them I know I've seen some
of it I'm like I can't tell if that just
looks familiar because I understand the
concept of the world and you've been to
conventions where they have a ton of
Doctor Who stuff up so you've seen these
actors portray characters and seeing
people cosplay yeah and everybody else
portraying these actors train these guys
so many fezzes and scarves everybody
loves Tom Baker too so like you know
scarves and stuff do you have a favorite
episode you have like an all-time
favorite a cuff like an underappreciated
episode well blink again was my interest
I think blink for scaring the crap out
of me as well as making me want to watch
Eccleston oh there's so many there's so
many mmm
bill is my favorite companion and Bill
was Paul Dee's second companion she
didn't last long which I was really sad
I thought she was cool and I liked how
she challenged the doctor have you ever
seen hitchhikers yeah Doctor Who is like
a TV version of Hitchhiker's Guide it
really is like especially in some of
that really cheeky humor too you know
basically all the same actors yeah that
was the other thing too as you called
him and like every major British actor
you could think of became a thing with
me my roommates when we were watching
because it's a big thing my roommates
and I always watched the new episode
together every week and we're like Oh
where's that person from and we tried to
see who can guess like who they played
in Game of Thrones or Harry Potter first
see now I want to start watching new
episodes and predicting which of these
actors is gonna blow up out of Doctor
Who doesn't feel like people do it like
right before they kind of get huge yeah
it's like a rite of passage to do Doctor
Who yeah you're not allowed to be a
British actor if you don't do that well
and and I love Maisie Williams is a huge
Doctor Who fan she plays Arya Stark
obviously in Game of Thrones and she was
such a Doctor Who fan after she became
famous with Game of Thrones asked to be
in an episode of Doctor Who and they did
I think but I'm like how cool is that
she better be yeah I mean she's going I
think she's come back I don't remember
but uh she's gonna be the next Doctor
she would be a great doctor I could
actually see that she's like 10 20 years
so now she'd be an amazing doctor Maisie
Williams for doctors she could yes she
could do the heavy but she could also do
the kind of charm the wonder you know
and she's just like cheeky as hell like
that's just like kind of her motif is
tongue-in-cheek type stuff so I would I
think she'd be great you guys seem
surprised to see me but there has also
been instances I believe and you can
correct me in the comments if I'm wrong
and I apologize but I think there have
been instances where actors have been
smaller roles and then about and casas
the doctor think this happened there's a
cat oh yeah we got to that's copper and
the other ones Todd you might appreciate
that if you pick it up yes yeah I still
I blink blink is what introduced me to
it and what's-her-name who blew up after
that Carey Mulligan Morgan so Carey
Mulligan that was one of her first big
TV roles was in that episode of Doctor
Who and that's like the only episode of
dr. hood she's in but you follow her
more than you follow any of the main
characters and dr. dam you know Doctor
Who good right of passage but they don't
really cast Americans unless
well there's one American who's cast is
what's his name Jack Jack Parsons Jack
Harkness the only American character I
know Doctor Who really
he must be that special
he's great and then he got a spinoff to
Torchwood yep I know things I know a
thing or two or two I mean I'm always
looking for approval so if you think I'm
fit to stay on my shower I appreciate
the most compliment but uh hey what's
your favorite episode of Doctor Who
comment below let us know I can't say
that's Jeremy Jones's thing subscribe to
the screen junkies though give them some
love always appreciate a good honest
trailer and you can subscribe to the
real rejects hit that notification bell
to get updated every time a review or a
video is out because the subscribe
button doesn't do that anymore I don't
know why it's what it's for but anyway
check us out on patreon also follow
Keaton Marky on the social media
Instagram Twitter all right yeah be well
people Cheers